the 49ers go back to metlife stadium
this weekend
after a week two game against the jets
that resulted in
multiple lower leg injuries nick boson
gone for the year with an acl
tear solomon thomas acl tower he most
her knee injury
the list goes on and on and peter the
report came out yesterday that all
parties involved
nfl nflpa they went back they took
another look at the field everything is
supposedly fine with the field
good luck convincing the 49ers of that
after what they went through this past
weekend
they believe there's an issue and
sometimes that just makes you even more
upset
when you're saying there's an issue and
no one's listening like when you take
your car into the shop and you're trying
to tell the mechanic there's an issue
and the mechanism i don't see a problem
no there's a problem
and and i don't you know the challenge
for the 49ers this weekend because
they're going to have to play on that
surface
kyle shanahan's got to get them to quit
thinking about it not worry about it
because there's nothing they can do
about it they have to go out and play
you know what kyle shanahan did was back
his players his players saying this turf
is
terrible but what really told me
something i heard ian rappaport talking
about this yesterday
mike is that you know it wasn't only
they had the two teams there
but they had they also had the nfl pa
there
and an independent turf specialist
to come in and to say here's what we
think about
this turf now you know you got to take
them at their word they
came out you know kumbaya this turf is
fine
so you know you're right he's got to
come out
this weekend and they have to play with
a severely
depleted team against the giants and
again
look everybody will look at the
jets and giants as an entry okay
they both stink one's the 31st team
one's a 32nd team no that isn't the case
the giants are not that bad the giants
could give the 49ers a game this weekend
and they could be very competitive this
weekend even without
saquon barkley uh and and look the
giants have their injuries too
but you're exactly right kyle shanahan
has to stand in front of him
saturday night or whether it's going to
be a virtual
meeting saturday and he's got to say hey
look remember when we were all
complaining about the turf
never mind you got to go out and play on
it tomorrow
so we'll see what kind of effect
it has but if you're a professional
you have to trust look i've seen the
union
in the past mike justifiably go crazy
about some surfaces in the nfl and the
fact that this union now
signs off on it i think the nf i think
the players on the 49ers have to say
okay we're okay with this because our
union has been
fiercely independent when it comes to
certifying fields
so i i do think the 49ers have just got
to suck it up
play on the field that they apparently
hate and
realize that you know maybe just maybe
there was a little bit of an
overreaction there or or
or the 49ers believe that the nflpa is
now part of the problem because no one's
listening to us either way they've got
to process
this by sunday and george kittle his
status in question
for sunday's game after suffering the
knee injury week one
will the 49ers hold him out an extra
week because they
do believe that there's an issue with
the turf that's going to be one of the
interesting questions as sunday rolls
around i think it's going to be very
hard
to keep george kittle off the field you
have to keep him out of the stadium
in order to keep him off the field
because he will play no matter what if
he feels like he's able to get out there
and move around